I believe that again as a child every
single one of these articles played an
important role a destructive role uh in
my growing up
to give any confirmation that I can
specifically remember reading the
Articles at the time I believe would be
speculation
yes as you said more than thousands
maybe millions of Articles have been
written about me since age 12.
yes because again because it's 20 years
ago I simply cannot speculate how it was
and whether I saw these articles at the
time I certainly saw lots of Articles at
the time
the ones I was made aware of because of
the behavior and reaction of people in
my inner circle
unfortunately stories that you've only
that I've only shared with one or two
people within my inner circle ends up
front page of newspaper or any page
your circle of friends starts to shrink
and diminish rather rapidly